if we will lost this junk it will be
temporary uh step i mean that's why i
call it manure because we need that we
have a different values
i mean we ukrainians and russians
because for them
uh
the life of
people doesn't matter nothing
uh for us it's our value so we need to
keep lives we need to save our people
and to continue our struggle
uh we need to
accumulate the forces
to make counter-attack
counter defeat
and i think that will be next stage from
the other side from what we've seen uh
we've heard air reporters spoken to
troops on the ground in missy shames and
they don't want to
to leave they want to stay and
fight
is that really what you want also or do
you think that at some point you might
have to retreat
i'm sure that all ukrainians
soldiers
want to liberate our territory till the
borders i mean international
recognized border includes crimea
includes donetsk and lugansk and we will
do it but we need the time we need more
weaponry from our partners
and we have brave we have desire
and i'm sure that we will do it
do you feel left out in the cold at all
because ukraine hasn't been invited to
be a nation member so
for us it's a very good precedent that
new membership is possible
also uh without any special um
conditions
do you honestly believe that you can win
this war
sure absolutely why are sitting here in
this position
in
in other cases i have to be in the
warsaw in poland or in london
or in
some kind of friendly countries because
we are on our land
it's our destiny
and i'm sure
that uh it's a difference between
two
civilized
um
probably values because we are on the on
the light side of the power
they are on a
dark side of the power what would be
your message to the kremlin the direct
message to the kremlin uh we are not
going to to to give up
uh
we are neighbor
and people who are living in russia
they will have
sons grandsons
daughters granddaughters
and you ruin this communication between
two nations for next
50 years what what keeps you awake at
night
who who is next minister of defense whom
i have to call and ask him more weaponry
it's absolutely true
because i get the new request from
general solutions we need more artillery
or need more uavs or need a special
needs for our
navy for example anti-missile ships and
i'm trying to find okay we can get it
from australia via the united kingdom
and we can communicate with the new
zealand aha okay i have to make three
phones to three ministers and ask them
to be on like a trio
it's
mind games in during my sleep also
what is your message i know we've
covered it before but your message to
nato as of today
uh
please
don't feel
any fatigue
please continue your support
don't be afraid to make new escalation
level with the russians because
absolutely honestly
the third world war
was started in
24 of february
this year
it's absolutely honestly and it's a real
life don't be afraid because we are
the first battlefield in this war if we
will fall down
next battlefield will be in
next european countries
don't be afraid and we will win together